بعد اشهر من المفاوضات السريه نشرت
المملكه المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
نستفاقهما الجديد لتحسين ترتيبات ما بعد
خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
لايرلندا الشماليه الاتفاق الذي يطلق عليه
اطار
حددت طرقا لتسهيل عمل ما يسمى ببروتوكول
ايرلندا الشماليه باكثر من 100 صفحه اطار
العمل الجديد يبقي مقاطعه ايرلندا
الشماليه في السوق الاوروبيه الموحده وضمن
الاتحاد الجمركي للتكتل وينص على اجراء
تفتيش للسلع المتجهه من بقيه انحاء
المملكه المتحده الى ايرلندا الشماليه
طبعا كما يهدف هذا الاطار الجديد الى
تحسين اداء البروتوكول في عده مجالات
رئيسيه سنستعرض ابرزها مثلا سيتم تقسيم
البضائع القادمه من بريطانيا الى ايرلندا
الشماليه سيتم تقسيمها الى فئتين الفئه
الاولى المتجهه الى ايرلندا الشماليه
ستكون بالم الاخضر وتلك المتجهه الى
ايرلندا والسوق الموحده للاتحاد الاوروبي
ستكون بالممر الاحمر الاتحاد الاوروبي كشف
ايضا ان الشركات التي تسجل في مخطط تاجر
موثوق به وتستخدم ايضا الممر الاخضر سيكون
لديها تخفيض غير مسبوق في الاوراق
الجمركيه ايضا سيتعين على البضائع
الموجوده في الممر ان تمر عبر فحوصات
الجمارك والغذاء والصحه ودائما للتدقيق
الكامل اما بالنسبه للاغذيه الزراعيه
فسيقبل الاتحاد الاوروبي معايير الصحه
العامه في المملكه المتحده ما يعني انه
سيتم السماح للحوم الطازجه وغيرها من
السلع بدخول ايرلندا الشماليه بعد ان يوضع
عليها ملصقات ليس للاتحاد الاوروبي ومع
ادخال الملصقات من الان وحتى عام 20 25
ستنخفض نسبه الشح نات الخاضعه للتحقق من
الهويه
ستنخفض الى 5% كما نتابع هنا وبالتالي
ستكون الاجراءات اقل تعقيدا واكثر سهوله
على الناس وايضا على الشركات
[موسيقى]